the hell hey photo what photo
what's thanks mr. Canada suspended it's
not my fault they said we're next
[Music]
we'll both meet up we'll have you walk
up you know I'll be coming in like this
and yet just exactly - just it's the
first discharge of critic of spring
good um let me get I felt that one
Benny
and action
Oh
one more you were fine I you know it's
wonderful when you see your Kim kids
play together ah
okay Jess here's your idea drop your
knees just dresses come to me
come on to me it's hard that I can't
really drop as well get kneepads hello
quicken from inside if you just want to
drop together so hi anglers well but I
think Doug's shooting down you'd see it
probably not I went to a grand endeavor
you could cheat it you could just show
me fall that's kind of despair just I
mean the one pat is grateful I just have
you coming just come to me I mean but
don't fake IRA's or doing an indoor
voice I mean just you can just come to
me I don't you can this Punia so good is
gamma do so these are gamma rays it's
actually a meteor it's like a meteor
that landed right here but you can still
be to me because they just let out
whatever beams when the comic book
initially is convenient
so we remain you're just beauty or calm
and cool yes listen to your heart aren't
you giant sack of space rock come to me
whatever you are the most comfortable
saying that bevy fine
patting yeah yep
all right you giant sack of space rock
come to me good
except it's Arielle girl you mean they
should be it is landed and what you're
doing is you're coming of you all right
yes Faison come to me oh it's just like
yeah and it's already later
yeah don't you read the scripts he
landed them what am i you're laying in
the rain you're laying the Rays
increasing the beeps are gonna consume
you just won't do it
it any feeds it just doesn't know Rob
you can talk down to it you know when
you do come to me correct yeah lay back
okay really just some of the cars pass
we don't know you with your director
what the batter is ready now we might as
well wait whoa oh yeah he just hits the
wall look out here
all right giant sack a space rock come
to me UH one more did do the arms at
that one is calling and saying yummy
yelling screams somebody is coming from
here yo
it's already landed when something gets
close it just convinced like a big oh
yeah now it can be either or at this
point so I guess you can point in front
makes more sense
I mean I'm this one doing front yeah I
don't stray wait so who can suspect
another birdie you go and get your balls
out alright okay you when you pointed
you said the meteor was over there
all right you giant sack a space rock
come to me the more I get really sweet
it oh yeah scream it's ready
I'll write you giant sack of space rock
come to me get good volume because you
know how to do it right have you done
and then your weight just like oh and
then it hits you that might be good okay
I don't know that fire okay no I can
edit it like that like the female Oh
like that'd be grand that I can okay
yeah there i'ma do my beard is pooping
it he doesn't she posted that on
Facebook yesterday that beards have poop
in them really it it's like a miniscule
amount I hate to tell you but
Mythbusters definitively proved that
poop is everywhere so it's just floating
in the air
you're just covered in shit oh no just
everywhere yeah that is everywhere here
say we're covered in feces the gang's
all here
good morning Angie oh yeah oh you're
gonna be a Skype meeting okay excuse me
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah a fan-made those
four edges to separate fans man yeah
aren't they amazing yeah yeah for those
figures I get the devil and for this
cleaner Santa Christ oh how about you
bitch earth Irving mica troll I can I
fix you oh no so strangely enough like
somebody made these it may want for
Malcolm to and that somebody made these
right as well too sick
yeah it's just only going on like the
only difference was that instead of them
both being with devil ah that didn't
wanna be the one for you Malcolm this
was carrot juice and this one was the
devil so you have those two it oh yeah
so so yeah you can
I can choose to ease off yeah there you
know right I'll go if you guys like no
I'm locking them in the vault there go
put it to the Disney Vault I mean yeah I
guess since we work for maker about time
actually since we work for maker
technically would be the damages oh no
help my association
those are really neat except I didn't
get one for me but then it was you happy
profit every pups look who's back so so
on my face look like demanded to know
where you were just like you know where
is about error well where till I am
stopping my foot right now I demand to
know it's just like oh well random
person persuaded my fan babe
I must tell you Tamara's giving her
boyfriend happy yes when I to her with
rasca right and every city that we went
to summary from nostalgia critic or
somebody up phantom stalker dick came up
it was like why are you here
hahahaha are you from ourselves gonna go
back to war
swears he on the Tuesday somebody was
like wait how did you feel that really
didn't keep in the day oh yeah edited in
the afternoon it's up by the night yep
okay we're so happy 11 them and you're
gonna do the shallot quite got before
ride you guys sir come up to us and what
when we're all like Malcolm said once I
have a grant like that all seniors
cameras cut off their that's when you'll
stop and when she stopped look over
where that yellow pole is just go go oh
and then run off and Rodney stay still
so so it's gonna be so it's gonna be us
skipping it all you know Rob comes up
this is yes soon as he stops yes
huh Tamara was alive
okay you guys guys together was a
monster no do the do the monkey whoa hey
hey we're the more ready Josie Joe what
the hell was that
the monkey this is why we're not doing
it that Wow children on this one he just
blew the hell out of ya well wait for
y'all going Oh Paul so yeah very much
wait for people starting
cheer up yep smiles up
[Applause]
oh-oh-oh
I do one more just a nice we had a big
meeting in the bathroom ready yep
Oh take a knee or purse which was more
comfortable for you
so yes we'll come in about here purple
bill we'll be looking this way
so we got come in about right here we're
going to look here and it's like I look
to the left to rob shoot pretty much all
right there oh you know we're getting
weirdly this meteor that landed up Oh
and then like you know like dad I'll
have you give the direct ran this just
see blowing and the yeah we're gonna be
on call and then boom and we're like oh
how much time between glowing and boom
like couple seconds got it okay so again
we're going to run in glowing boom
and
don't you know me she's stretching it's
a humorist
okay just effect
[Applause]
glowing boom okay so yeah love you we
gonna be shoulder shoulder glowing boom
good
baby breath roll glowing boom door we're
gonna stop about right here just ah we
just feel look at you Tamara you look at
me they look at you Malcolm you look at
me
they look forward that I look at you
Tamara you look at me I look at you
Malcolm you look at me and then we look
forward we're just doing it we just keep
doing yeah and you're just gonna get
this for you like a low-angle a kind of
medium shy do so still like right from
the waist up to them
you got enough light from yo yeah I was
bringing a light that would know Tamra's
backing ready for actually let's super
powder tragedy I'm like that
what is it famous before yeah the thing
you're here the clobber I don't know if
it has very much yeah I don't even know
who my it's glue opera guy do your
pictures of cameras thing yeah Wow Wow
where do you think you get all your
talent from Rob it's not genetic oh I'm
the pixel later er I can't wait for this
week's fine it's gotta be something with
this in our superheroes
yeah soon I'm the pixel 800 gyms mask
feels really neat really looks like
monitor down a set of sunglasses you can
get it on and off right yes I'm excited
well I no no no I know that that's only
for like this cuz they're gonna wonder
what the hell this game shows amazing
figure out how to make the three
seashells work right gives us seashells
okay so this one uh a proud maybe
just serve a sort of a shot like this
isn't gonna be looking my hands like you
want me to do a full bunny uh yeah like
a 180 in that and on a close-up of me
just nodding like yeah right yeah Oh
[Music]
Malcolm get over dad Ross okay ready yep
and action
I saying this once you can start off
like tight on the hands pull out and
then pull out the face yeah like that
then okay yeah like that and then yeah
ty amethyst action
okay look at ridiculous
okay uh this one is gonna let's see we
need a yum this is where Malcolm turns
his monkey gosh yes
I've always wanted to do that here you
have very specific aspirations and yeah
antes yes I've always liked to turn my
coffee mugs
I don't even know what the word is for
that finish donkey donkey donkey donkey
donkey mugging we've invented a new
fetish turn donkey mugging
I've always going to turn my mug in the
Dom okay
don't question it Doug just give it a
Sisson thank you um I think what we'll
do is not a bad idea okay I hear we'll
put you over here as well I think we're
always just gonna have like this is just
the area where we discover our horse
this way I think we'll do is it still
jacket we don't think that's gonna get
over the top what it is or I mean I
don't at uh but just for kind of them
yeah um I keep you be near the coffee
table or something all right
maybe maybe maybe over there might be
good because that way you can have they
are even right here like yeah I think I
like so pondering like the finger gadget
that's not bad well like that yeah
that's great this is it course makes
sense now DK hey that's half a dick
donkey mugging oh yes
and when I say go you're gonna have to
like you know donkey time he raids about
this high
oh it's like you know whoa is he on the
floor
oh yeah he's on the floor white goo poo
oh yeah the real donkey
like a yes the real Donkey Kong Malcolm
I gave him a call he likes bananas
no curious Malcolm say laughter jockeys
god it's so good to see is a monkey sure
is kidding I'll just I think we all just
had a nervous break the badness with it
okay so I'm gonna come in so yes I say
action monk you're just gonna go like
yeah like exactly like that I think
that's good and I'll say freeze you hold
it Rob you take away the mug I'll say go
and you'll be like it up Oh Donkey Kong
whoa yeah okay there are you for this uh
probably not but if you want to make
some sounds or something that's fine
okay okay ready Malcolm mm-hmm hey
pretty rep ready and action
freeze
and go whoa Nintendo
his name is donkey cut damn it good on
this one
um I got a lot more like it Wow Wow just
kinda like yeah okay ready market and
action freeze go oh good hi he's out of
here gonna be a little sure he's gonna
be about that tall there's a look down a
little bit yeah yeah you're looking up a
little bit uh and yet the reactions you
have it you can just go right into that
Wow okay okay make sure to get it in
some Donkey dollars yeah oh you're
welcome
yeah yeah good good stern boy I don't
know okay no no your Hulk it off throw
yourself into it it's a wrestling match
yeah just Tully no I'm super fucking
strong engine I better jump well just
hand the fanfic writers their keyboards
is this like a thing like Hulk with it
there's a shit there is a CEO and she is
a walker
thank you very much shashi mark turning
bad ass kicked I guess I just sorry the
woman doesn't mean it's like oh I like
you less you're David going er ok fair
enough
why I can't just be a strong jumper no
sure woman you're immediately sexualized
like give it breath oh that's odd you're
a Nobel laureate the ends of this DC or
marvel ride ride a superhero by night
works at McDonald's okay she-hulk versus
rogue woodwind practice that be an
intention there you go
yeah I I even say when women come white
girls can't jump yes I'd even say when
you when you come down to make it look
like your point like all you're trying
to do yes or like fool you know serve
like at the Bible yeah just let your
hair her hair turns completely blue is a
good be funny or she just like went
right through the floor did I read my
hand actually I might rappers know that
that's pretty funny too uh if I can't
get mirror effect or just go from before
okay alright let's right now and this
one you're just smashing the building
bills okay
chest everybody can do okay great Tamara
and action
it's like a Pilates to see your feet
like hip before like Oh on this one
we'll have you do it yet it show the
feet hit the floor if I sort of shake it
a little bit too when she lands oh you
wanted shit okay yeah it's good have the
options this so yeah all right great
Taylor hey Rob yep and action
I don't know some day like not it's like
a rock concert just like what it oh yes
should be like one of the the nerdy ones
from fine fine static Oh Berta Oh Berta
fine she was so terrible like you want
it is beauty it's the worst thing I've
seen since Denise Richards as a nuclear
physicist it is that level of
embarrassing Jessica Alba playing a
scientist oh and I'm not saying she is
incapable of doing it but the way the
role was written in the way she was
directed everything is just like they're
just like yeah just throw some glasses
on her I'm sure the audience of buy it
read it strutting around and her sexy
skin tight outfit like these sockets
it's going to last since you stole
through the end I see
yeah me going home down I don't okay
okay yeah we can't buy everything we
call that the Sally Jessy Raphael
oh those a yes oh my god yeah oh my
goodness oh it's a transformation can
you see enough yeah okay oh there you go
yeah yeah really is Excelsior okay yeah
yeah scooch in there you go 3d glasses
okay keep some tell ya how does first
name of Gruffudd I could put them on
display him yeah it you can clearly see
oh it's in the i io a n is it said maybe
a 1 or 1
III think I got to use that no it's just
a you can see real freedom but I was
almost thinking about just having you'd
be like the scientist from food fighters
they'll have like the plague gloves and
stuff like that guy's got a demagogue oh
you're gravitas just went up a hundred
percent Malcolm with those glasses yes
okay
too ugly it's impossible you guys can
have like the pictures like Alec in
between you
oh yeah you like this oh no and we can
actually see the back cuz we're gonna do
one other shower you see oh that's a yes
I see you can do it like this yeah okay
so too ugly to average you to bald to
wrinkly
Oh to normal uh-huh what about now these
are people now these are the people
qualified to go up into space but these
are the little but these are just oh but
these are just the glamour images
magazines no they're perfect call them
immediately
alright remember you take the magazine's
then you grab they're perfect
call them immediately it's ever this one
haha except for this one
yeah yeah Tamra I like you play today
you know call them immediately that's
good so that way you can pull it back
that's really good okay you know
father's always want to be so proud of
their sons what can I say about Doug you
can't get any more proud than that say
Ron say it gay pride and loving it
yeah quote dude you know you want to
like I like sting just getting out of
that big beehive thing why would I want
salt sting like that
and then I will send you a fade hey
cousins are mates it is amazing get the
clobberer Thank You Father
clobberer at first I thought I said
cobbler that's like didn't you say your
name for this tell me where
one-two-three sparky-sparky boom man
it's sparky-sparky boom be good this is
fine done going up there we'll be heroes
instead shot and miles morass cops like
no no honey no no well one thing I got
you only only Malcolm isms hears you've
already have a place here
yeah scuba what a story
Hillary NASA say that again what a story
ah actually I love the fire we have like
a pro meals to prevent die I like this
better because we yes squash on the rock
last time we saw a baby well in your
suits all dirty yeah yeah no no she
should never she just got out of the
ruffle just want to be big story okay so
uh Jim you're going to be next to
Malcolm go ahead and again actually both
of you step forward a bit good and let's
step that way yeah um okay so what's
going to be Malcolm you're going around
promoting us because that's all they did
in Fantastic Four and um here I'll get
you a check out my face not we what that
yes I'm the pics later see wait then
who's filming okay so um so we say you
know I'd you guys gonna do it no that's
cool Malcolm it was out earlier
promoting us so turn on the TV and says
let's see so that this is what's on the
TV it's like you know it there's gotta
be lights flashing around you and mouth
you can be talking about just a brief
reminder that we're still amazing even
though we've done very little with our
amazingness and Jim you say welcome how
do you respond to people saying that
your powers are just a ripoff of the new
Adam Sandler and you pay what you just
touch him like that and when I say
freeze Jim you just walk out and I'll
say action and you just go oh no you
turn to pre-much 64 more - you run off
and yeah that's it and Maggie just
continued to wave everyone's stuff
so reason you're gonna look it over a
little bit more if you want while I
frame the shot we're still amazing even
though we've done very little with our
amazingness nothing how do you respond
people saying that your powers are
nothing more than ever oh god just
another excuse to make us all look
ridiculous I blame it all on Doug but I
got to admit this time he may take the
cake yes is just the most ridiculous
you look like gay Big Bird I make it
watch straight big birds blatantly it
does it big boy photo photo
thanks mr. Canada it's not my fault they
still win it fixed again Tamara pull
that black thing on Doug's neck out of
the room yes there you go you know like
that like the cameras going to be
tracking in we all just do some kind of
photo is just looking at the camera like
you know imagine the American flag here
your action show on TV shot where it
gives the conscious Turner all right
ready and action
good yeah I mean I stop at some point
that's what you want yeah yeah so we're
slight Dutch angle profile yeah good
okay
make sure the focus is either on auto or
thank you if the fantastic four is
taught us anything it's that we don't
have to what is about the fantastic four
that you can't catch a break in terms of
movies I think Brad to the new one
hasn't come out yet but it's gonna suck
probably getting much yeah
please be that bit and we do it again
just do that you know that just she says
her life because I think it's too long
wait okay ready
Oh table we serve a villain always a fat
Mary doll Cassidy trussoni victim in my
god
having a moment of surprise is a repin
you're scared I'm homosexual yeah you
know that's irrelevant crazy fuck well
you're not surrounded soda but your ass
Oddity shoes that are guys like happy
shoes well y'all dressed roughly yes
recording and out of context you were
going to be wandering for the rest of
time what the hell was about never
explained don't we love it now it's you
got some in front of right behind your
boom but not inside your shirt
Wow what better rayon that's okay that
might sound strange
no it's perfect is that they will go
away down yeah okay Steve as you
probably I could pick them up a little
bit somewhere I'm giving birth to a new
kind of porn out all free yeah we're all
gonna stand up yeah
this looks like a job when you have AK
William Preston 3 yeah we just walk out
there okay - you should just get up like
this
yeah I'll stand up like really proud of
you
so this looks like so unlike that's
where you guys are coming this looks
like a job for the other Queen
impressive three and minnow okay okay oh
I got a fine side okay open another bag
well then no should be one already open
yeah looks like you're storing nuts for
the winter phrases you never want to
hear let's load up Doug's your are close
to Doug um so that you're in the show
okay so yeah I got me I'm sure you know
how this where Leo this you know so yes
I'll say action this yeah I mean for
sure and Ajay keep your hands down low
but you know it's gonna have to be below
dog's belly button basically okay so no
higher than this yeah okay can you okay
and then Tamra and uncle
[Music]
you